[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم بلينكن يقول ان رد حماس
على مقترح صفقه التبادل يتيح مجالا للتوصل
الى اتفاق ويؤكد التزام واشنطن باقامه
دوله فلسطينيه حماس ترسل وفدا الى القاهره
لاستكمال محادثات وقف اطلاق النار برعايه
قطريه نصريه ونتنياهو يقول ان المفاوضات
مستمره بالتزامن مع استمرار الحرب في حين
اكد جانتس ل بلينكن ان الاولويه الان
ايجاد طريقه لاستعاده الرهائن وتجدون
المزيد من اخبار حرب غزه في رابط بالتعليق
الاول القياده الوسطى الامريكيه تعلن قتل
قائد بارز في كتائب حزب الله العراقي
بغاره في بغداد الحشد الشعبي يؤكد مقتل
القيادي ابو باقر الساعدي ورئيس الوزراء
العراقي يندد بالقصف ويقول ان وجود قوات
التحالف اصبح يزعزع استقرار العراق ما
يدفع الحكومه الى العمل على انهاء مهمه
التحالف
الدولي شركه ميرسك الدنماركيه للشحن
البحري تعلن تراجع ارباحها بنسبه
87% على اساس سنوي خلال الربع الاخير من
العام الماضي بسبب الازمه في البحر الاحمر
واستبداله بطريق راس الرجاء الصالح الذي
زاد في نفقات الوصول الى الوجهات النهائيه
للحاويات مشيره الى توقعات متشائمه حيال
ارباحها خلال العام الجاري ميتا تعتزم وضع
علامات لتمييز الصور المولده بتقنيه
الذكاء الاصطناعي المنشوره على منصاتها
الثلاث فيسبوك انستغرام وثر في اجراء يهدف
حسب الشركه للحد من انتشار الصور الزائفه
والتي تثير مخاوف من استخدامها لاثاره
فوضى سياسيه من خلال التضليل الاعلامي او
نشر معلومات خاطئه الى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء